[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing ones ones are an essential
part of any witch or wizard's arsenal an
object with which they are able to
channel and hone their magical abilities
when witches and wizards come of age and
their time finally comes for them to
head off to hogwarts one of the first
places they go in preparation for the
school year is ollivanders it's at
olivander's makers of fine ones since
382 bc that many witches and wizards are
paired with the wand that they will keep
for their entire life the one that they
form a real connection with as ones are
quasi-sentient they possess the ability
to choose the wizard rather than the
other way around which is why ones are a
very personal item we know harry's wand
and a few others are mentioned but what
about all the other characters in
today's video i want to break down the
ones of 20 harry potter characters and
explain what these ones mean without
further ado let's get started
hermione granger hermione granger's wand
is made of fine wood a less common type
of wonder wood that tends to generally
suit witches and wizards who seek a
greater purpose
vine is also drawn to personalities with
hidden depths the core of her wand is
dragon heartstring one of the most
powerful but temperamental one core
materials derived from dragons the
length of a wand is ten and three
quarter inches which is pretty much
normal
voldemort though voldemort eventually
procures the elder wand at one point he
was appointed a wand at olivander's just
like everyone else his first wand was
made of
13 and a half inches in length and was a
phoenix feather core this wand is
arguably one of the most infamous
destructive ones in the entire harry
potter universe and was responsible for
the famous scar on harry's forehead u is
a rarer one to type which tends to be
drawn to more unusual people it also
retains a fierce reputation in the
spheres of duelling gilderoy lockhart
gilderoy lockhart's wand was nine inches
long and made of cherry wood with the
dragon heart string core
the short length of lockhart's wand is
representative of the fact that his
personality is lacking in some ways
cherrywood is common for students at
mahutukuro the magical school in japan
and creates a wand of strange power ron
weasley ron weasley had two ones over
the course of the story the first was a
hand-me-down which was 12 inches and
made of ash with a unicorn hair core his
second wand was 14 inches long made of
willow and also had a unicorn hair core
the great length of his wand is
representative of his larger than life
personality and the willow wood used is
an uncommon wood type which is purported
to possess healing power willow ones
have consistently selected those of
greatest potential rather than those who
feel they have little to learn
neville longbottom neville longbottom
had two ones the first was a
hand-me-down and little is known about
it his second wand however was 13 inches
long and made of cherry wood with a
unicorn hair core like ron the length of
his wand is representative of his
strength of character unicorn hair cores
generally produce the most consistent
magic and are the most faithful of all
ones bellatrix lestrange bellatrix the
strangers wand was 12 and three-quarter
inches long and made of walnut with the
dragon heartstring core though evil the
length of bellatrix's wand in
conjunction with her small stature would
suggest that she has a strong character
walnut ones are often found in the hands
of magical inventors and are
particularly versatile bellatrix's wand
was often described as unyielding draco
malfoy draco malfoy's wand was 10 inches
long and made of hawthorne with a
unicorn hair core draco's wand was once
described by olivander as reasonably
springy hawthorne ones are often paired
with witches and wizards that have a
conflicted nature and for this reason
the hawthorne fits draco perfectly
minerva mcgonagall minerva mcgonagall's
wand was nine and a half inches long and
made of fur with the dragon heart string
core what stuck out to me about her wand
is the length as it is quite short as
far as ones go sometimes but not always
indicating a lack of strength of
character like with lockhart however in
mcgonagall's case the short length of
her wand may solely be due to her small
physical stature fur ones are
particularly suited to transfiguration
her specialty quironus quirrell cronus
corals wand was nine inches long and
made of older with the unicorn hair core
coral's extremely short wand is
undoubtedly the result of its narrow
personality and feeble nature older wood
ones generally seek witches and wizards
that represent characteristics
considered to be the opposite of what
the wood itself represents
hagrid the story of hackers 1 is lengthy
and i know that he later uses the
umbrella but once upon a time hagrid's
wand was fully intact hagrid's wand was
16 inches long made of oak with an
unknown core oak ones are said to have
an affinity with magic of the natural
world and expertly suit witches and
wizards that work with creatures and
plants the length of hagrid's wand is
representative of his giant stature and
larger than life personality circadogan
circa dogan's wand was nine inches long
and made of black thorn the troll
whisker core blackthorne ones are best
suited to warriors can be found in the
possession of many prodigious witches
and wizards troll whisker cores on the
other hand are considered to be barely
passable wonderful materials horus
slughorn horus slughorn's wand was ten
and a quarter inches long and made of
cedar with a dragon heartstring core
cedar ones are drawn to those with
incredible strength of character and
propensity for immense loyalty peter
pettigrew peter pettigrew's one was nine
and a quarter inches long and made of
chestnut with a dragon heartstring core
his short one length is in my eyes
certainly representative of his mental
weakness and stunted character chestnut
ones are pretty versatile but are often
drawn to witches and wizards that are
gifted tamers of magical beasts however
this can change greatly depending on the
core with which it is paired remus lupin
remus lupin's wand was ten and a quarter
inches long and made of cyprus with a
unicorn hair core the great medieval
wondermaker garant ollivander wrote that
he was always honored to match a cypress
wand for he knew he was meeting a witch
or wizard who would die a heroic death
couldn't be more fitting lucius malfoy
lucius malfoy's wand was 18 inches long
and made of elm with a dragon heart
string core i should mention that the
length of lucius's wand can be
attributed to the addition of a silver
snakehead handle i'm not sure how long
the actual wand is element ones are very
sophisticated ones which are capable of
highly advanced magic in the right hands
fleur de la cour flu de la course wand
was nine and a half inches long and made
of rosewood with the villa hair core
rosewood is a very rare wonder wood
representing love and purity that is not
used by ollivander vela hair cores which
come from vela like fleur are said to be
highly temperamental
celestina warbeck celestina warback's
wand was ten and a half inches long a
medal arch with the phoenix feather core
large wood ones are said to be
incredibly attractive and powerful but
also very hard to please victor crum
victor crumb's wand was ten and a
quarter inches long made of hornbeam
with a dragon heartstring core hornbeam
ones are known for being expertly
matched with the witch or wizards style
of magic and become extremely
personalized very quickly making them
nearly impossible to use in the hands of
anyone else ollivander the wondermaker
himself garrick olivander had a 12 and
three quarter inch wand made of hornbeam
with a dragon heartstring core he had
this to say of his own wand my own wand
is made of hornbeam and so it is with
all due modesty that i state that
hornbeam selects for its lifemate the
talented witcher wizard with a single
pure passion which some might call
obsession simple trelloni sybil trelawny
had a nine and a half inch wand made of
hazel with the unicorn hair core hazel
ones are said to work best for those who
are able to master the art of
understanding and managing their own
feelings not sure this was the best
pairing and that's it for this video i
hope you guys learned something about
the ones of some of your favorite
characters if you enjoy the content
please like the video and subscribe to
the channel until next time the wand
chooses the wizard mr potter
[Music]
you